24 rules of investing these are all
structured as if then statements if we
learn a principle then we can continue
to use that winning principle over and
over again the reason some of the
greatest investors publish books about
their principles is because they know if
people make the right decisions they get
the right outcomes over a long enough
time Horizon my abduction and I make
these videos because I hope that if you
have a 3 million to 100 million dollar
company you'll ask us to invest in it
and we can help you grow up
if you can't buy it twice don't buy it
once and realistically probably three
four five six times when I got into
investing I used to think oh I'm going
to put like a third into this they're
like dude no your biggest allocation
might be 10 oh if you can't buy twice
don't buy once
if you're worried about it you can buy
insurance for it you can get insurance
on anything
for example people like I'm afraid of
running out of money you can literally
buy money for the rest of your life you
can literally give money and they will
have a guaranteed income until you die
which are called annuities so if you
have a specific concern just buy
insurance for it and know that it's
covered
if a deal feels like a grand slam get a
second opinion whenever I'm looking at
something and something looks amazing I
automatically send it to other people I
must not be seeing something like I need
someone else's eyes on this it's a good
easy decision making rule for yourself
for investing
if you don't know how you can lose money
don't do it until you do there's always
a way to lose money in the deal and you
not only want to find a way to lose
money but you want to find all the ways
you can lose money in the deal right
we're always controlling for the unknown
or the unknowable we want to minimize
that the highest degree possible so if
you don't know how you can lose money
don't do the deal until you do
if it feels rushed don't do it a lot of
people will try and apply pressure to
you they're trying to say like hey do
this deal with me hey give me this money
hey can you lend me this thing if
someone tries to pressure you pause if
you feel rushed don't do it
if you only have one deal on the table
don't do the deal always have backup
deals imagine you're dating and there's
only one girl on the planet you're gonna
find a way to think that that girl and
if you know your gender's reverse flip
right whatever you know what I'm saying
there's only one person on the planet
then you're gonna find a way to make
that work and so it's kind of the same
thing with deals if you only have one
deal on the table you're going to keep
telling yourself man maybe this is a
good deal because you have nothing else
to compare it to you always want to have
a plethora of options to choose from and
until you get those many options to
choose from don't move forward because
what happens is you artificially make
that girl look a lot better or that
person or that deal looks a lot better
when there's nothing else compared to
if you buy with the intention of selling
you're not investing you're trading
investing is about very very long time
Horizons it's a whole different set of
rules where you get in trouble is where
you're trying to apply business stuff to
investing or investing stuff to business
like they are different skills to master
if we don't agree we don't do it this
comes into play when you have a
partnership this has saved me so many
mistakes because I'm usually the Yes man
I tend to see more upside and less
downsides most entrepreneurial people
are that way because we have to be
because if we actually focused on the
likelihood of success which is usually
low for most entrepreneurial things you
would never get started it's good a to
have a partner who balances that b they
actually have to balance it if they're
just a Yes Man and they always bend to
your will then they're not actually
providing value there's a reason yin and
yang are equally weighted in the symbol
if you don't agree don't move forward
even if I have decision-making Authority
I still won't move forward until we
agree as a tangent into marriage stuff
we get asked this all the time they're
like well you know push comes to show
somebody has the upper hand honestly no
we keep talking about until we agree we
don't make the decision until we both
agree and it's been one of the earliest
pieces of advice we got and it's been
one of the ones that paid us the most
dividends
if it's complicated pass if it feels
above your head it probably is people
want to feel fancy they want to get into
the room they want to do these deals but
if you don't get it you're gonna get
[__] if you have complete
understanding of something the risk goes
down because you understand the
variables you're barely catching on you
might as well be gambling which is not
the way to invest
fomo means slow down so if you feel that
emotion you're like I'm gonna miss out
on something slow down this is a
decision making variable when you feel
that emotion slow down these are
principles you start flexing these like
muscles if this then that if this then
that it preserves your ability to make
better decisions over time and if you
apply all of these things to all the
decisions you make you will have outside
returns over a longer time Horizon
no diligence no deal if you don't get
the information you need to make the
decision you don't make the decision and
I know this sounds ridiculous but many
of you do this you just go off the hype
you go off an email or a phone call get
the information you need
no model no deal if someone doesn't send
me their proposal for how something's
going to grow or how something's going
to improve or how they're going to add
value and there's no deal I don't want
to hear a story of it I want to see the
math behind it I want to see the
projections and then when I look at
those things I can make the decision
like is this reasonable what assumptions
is this based on do I think those
assumptions are reasonable or probable
and what information can I bring to this
decision what are the things I need to
believe that have to be true for this to
occur
if someone's non-responsive No Deal
communication is one of the most
important things when you're doing any
kind of business in general and I judge
someone very quickly on how meticulous
they are in their responses and how
quick they are to respond in general now
if someone says hey I received your
email I'll get back to you in two days
and then they get back to me in two days
that's fine it's about expectation
setting and expectation meeting I expect
especially in this process where I'm
just getting to know you what you say is
going to happen is going to happen it's
one of the easiest ways to build a
reputation is do what you're going to
say say what you're going to do and if
someone's not doing that with you don't
do the deal
if it costs peace of mind don't buy it
so if anything costs me my sleep or
something that I'm worried about as a
result of me making an investment or a
purchasing decision I don't buy it
because the cost is too high
if it doesn't build your reputation
don't do it no neutral moves your brand
personally your reputation is the one
thing that you take with you forever and
you absolutely can lose it and it can be
irreparably damaged I'd only do it if it
fills my reputation when we do that we
continue to reinvest in our reputation
in our personal brand which gives us
compounding returns over our entire
lifespan in terms of relationships in
terms of literally Financial return in
all other aspects of Life only invest if
it builds your reputation if it doesn't
build don't do it
no track record No Deal performance over
Charisma the best predictor of future
performance is past performance sure
they have a model fantastic oh they're
allowing us to do diligence great oh
they're being very responsive phenomenal
but if they have no track record
might they be successful yes but if I
invest in every deal that doesn't have
track records is that a good way to
invest probably not like Napoleon like
to say I'd rather have lucky generals
someone's gonna probably do their deal
it doesn't have to be you
if it's the same thing you've always
done well with do more of it we as
humans or entrepreneurs we like having
variety the thing is is that a lot of
investing a lot of compounding comes
from doing more of the same thing so
it's like hey man I've done three hard
money loans and they've all been awesome
it's like well then you should probably
consider doing a fourth rather than
starting to get into crypto day trading
what happens is you start to build your
own track record and so you can start
looking back over your shoulder be like
okay let's look at all the things that
I've done these have been the things
that have worked well maybe I'm better
at this stuff and so that's the idea
once you find something you're starting
to get good at do more of it because the
thing is is that your luck will improve
the more you do
always under borrow any number no matter
how big it is multiplied by zero is
still zero I tend to be very risk-averse
when it comes to debt debt introduces
risk into any equation if you are going
to borrow then under borrow so even
though you could juice your return by
getting more remember that there is a
likelihood over a long enough time rise
in that if you over juice on a
consistent basis you will get zero
always under borrow then you won't make
as much money but you won't lose it
ask stupid questions Define terms draw
pictures see examples and if you can't
draw it back you don't get it I start
every single call when somebody's gonna
bring me something I'll be like pretend
I'm a golden retriever that doesn't
speak English walk me through this
there's no advantage to somebody
thinking you know more than you do not
but there is advantages to you knowing
more than they think you do always play
the fool
if we're not in the GP we're not in the
deal once you have 10 20 you know 30
million in investable assets just say I
want a part of the GP I don't know what
the GP is it's General partner limited
partner the people with General partners
are basically the people who run the
thing so they get an exercise to the pie
versus the limited partners who actually
invest the money we only do deals that
we're part of the GP because I want to
make sure that we have a part of the
people who are really running this thing
if it's a bad person it's a bad deal
Layla has an impeccable people picker
it's unbelievable my entire
relationship's never been wrong and it's
why I've been wrong all the time I'm
like this guy's great Layla's never been
wrong bad Partners doesn't matter what
the paper says don't do it there are so
many reasons you should not do a deal
you should be saying no way more than
you should be saying yes
no contract no deal this is a really
important one for me gotta have
contracts for everything contracts serve
the purpose of setting clear expectation
what happens if you lose all my [__]
what happens if you don't do what you
said you're gonna what happens if I
don't do what I said I was going to do
what happens like you got to walk
through that if you can't walk through
in the beginning you're definitely not
going to walk through it when it
actually happens and anyone who says I
only do handshake deals I don't do
contracts run the other way not once has
someone approached me that way and they
not being unbelievably Shady if there's
anything you get for this video if
someone says I don't believe in
contracts be like I don't believe in
dealing deals without contracts sorry
clear expectations good
if you're the one people are doing
business with I like to pretend like the
contract doesn't exist you absolutely
want to be clear when you're writing the
contracts and the terms but then as soon
as that process is over live as though
the contract doesn't exist negotiate it
as though it's the only thing that
matters let's say I have a Services
relationship that's a year-long I want
to mentally think even though they've
committed to a year I'm only week to
week they don't have to pay me next
month if you go on the defensive when
you're Contracting but you go on the
offensive when you're in delivery you
kind of get the best of both worlds